اقدم ما قبله بشريه تكتشفها وتكشفها دراسه
جديده تشير الى ان اقدم قبله على شفاه
مسجله في بلاد ما بين النهرين اي العراق
وسوريا في الوقت الحاضر تعود هذه العاده
الى الف عام من الوثائق المكتشفه سابقا
كانوا رومانسيين على فكره يعني يعني تعود
هذا او هذه القبله تعود الى قبل حوالي
4500 عام وكانت القبلات شائعه لتحيه افراد
الاسره ليس فقط في العلاقات العاطفيه
استدل الباحثون على نتائجهم من الواح
طينيه ومن رسومات وكتابات بالخط المسماري
ومن ضمن النتائج الاخرى فان التقبيل ربما
يكون قد لعب دورا عن غير قصد في انتقال
الفيروسات ايضا حتى عندهم كورونا
حتى عندهم كورونا مزبوط ما تلقحوا شايف
الانسان يعني من اكثر من 4500 سنه او 5000
سنه برضه رومانسي ومحب على فكره ترى ما
ادري يمكن البعض ما يحبها ولكن القبله
سواء يعني حتى في سلامنا هذه هي فيها اكثر
حميميه بالتالي تشعر الاخر بهذا الترحاب
حتى اذا بتلاحظ الاطفال الصغار دائما
بيكتشفوا العالم عن طريق فمهم ففي اتصال
دائما ما بين الفم وما بين يعني لذه
وتجربه جديده دائما لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات